- [Voiceover] The submarine
captain starts ascending
at a constant angle of
inclination of 20 degrees
so that he can surface in 5,000 feet,
so it looks like this,
the submarine is right here,
and he starts surfacing,
he starts ascending at
an angle of 20 degrees
so he's just going on that direction,
so this is our angle of 20 degrees,
and he wants to surface.
So I guess this is the
surface right over here
of the water.
He wants to surface
after traveling 5,000 feet
in the horizontal direction.
Changes in pressure are very important
in submarine travel, and the pressure
in kilopascals is given by the equation
the pressure in kilopascals
is approximately 2.990
times your depth in your depth,
and I guess it's going to be feet,
plus 101.3.
What is the current pressure, P,
on the submarine at depth D?
Round your answer to
the nearest kilopascal.
All right.
So if we can figure out,
and they've kind of drawn a
nice right triangle for us,
where this angle right
over here is 20 degrees,
and so if we can use a
little bit of mathematics
to figure out what D is,
then we can substitute D into this formula
right over here and
figure out the pressure
in terms of kilopascals
at this starting depth
right over here.
Well, how do you do that?
Well, if you're dealing
with a right triangle
and you know an angle
and you know one of the sides,
you might remember
that you're trig,
your definitions of your trig functions
might come in handy.
And for just basic right triangles,
you always want to refer to soh cah...
Soh cah toa,
where soa says that side is equal to
side of an angle is equal
to the ratio of the opposite
side to the hypotenuse.
Cosine of an angle is equal to the ratio
of the adjacent to the hypotenuse.
And tangent of an angle is equal to
the ratio of the opposite
side to the adjacent side.
So we have our angle here.
Now what sides are we trying to deal with?
We're trying to deal with
this side right over
here is the opposite side
and if any of this looks foreign to you,
I encourage you to
review the basic
trigonometry on Khan Academy.
And then this side right over here,
it's not the hypotenuse.
It's the adjacent side.
You could argue that the
hypotenuse is also right next to it,
so some people would call it adjacent
but we would call this the hypotenuse,
that is
the longest side of the right triangle.
And then the adjacent side
that is not the hypotenuse,
that's the one that we
call the adjacent side,
so this is the adjacent side.
So, we're going to be
dealing with the opposite
and the adjacent.
So which trig function
comes into play here?
Well, tangent deals with the opposite
and the adjacent.
So we know that the tangent,
the tangent of 20 degrees
is going to be equal to the ratio
of the opposite side to...
or the length of the opposite side
to the length of the adjacent side.
So it's going to be
D feet over 5,000 feet
or if we want to solve for D
we could just multiple both
sides of this by 5,000.
Multiple both sides by 5,000
and we're gonna get D is equal to,
I'm just swapping sides here,
is going to be equal to
5,000 times the tangent
of 20 degrees
and then we could take
whatever this value is
and substitute it down
down here and round to
the nearest kilopascal.
Well tangent of 20 degrees,
we're gonna need a calculator for that,
and luckily we have one.
Now when you do this,
when you use your calculator,
you want to be very careful
that you are in the correct mode,
so you want to be very careful
that you are in degree mode.
Depending on your calculator,
there's different ways of going between
degree and radian mode
and I encourage you to
get familiar with that.
That's just going to be useful for you,
potentially on the SAT, but for sure
when you're in trigonometry class
but I'm in degree mode here.
So I could take,
I could take 20 degrees
and take the tangent of it.
So that's this right over here
and then multiply it times 5,000.
So times five, one, two, three,
is going to be equal to this.
So that's my depth.
1,819.8511...you know,
it keeps going, feet.
And now I can substitute into...
into this formula.
So let's see, if I want to take our D,
this is our D,
multiply it by 2.990.
So let's multiply it
by two point nine nine,
well I could store a zero there
but it's not gonna change the value,
is equal to that
and then add 101.3.
So plus 101.3
is equal to
5,542.65500
and let's see, I want to round
to the nearest kilopascal.
This P here is given in kilopascals,
so it's gonna be 5,540, I'm gonna round up
'cause I have a point six here.
5,543.
So,
P is approximately 5,543,
5,543 kilo...
kilopascals
kilopascals, based on the information,
based on the information
that they gave us.
Put a comma there,
not a decimal, a comma.
There you go.